a lot of the work
we did is practical sir you weren't
anticipating that you were not
anticipating that
the ledge oh this whole setup of this
gag
this is where i got hurt
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
episode of vfx artists react stick
around to the end to figure out how you
can get 15 off your order
hey welcome back to another episode of
stuntman react we are here today with
aaron tony now aaron
is quite accomplished aaron what do you
say is your specialty and what things
might have we have seen you in
well i started in taekwondo i've got
probably about 15 years in the business
i've worked on everything from power
rangers pirates of the caribbean captain
america civil war
all right so we have some clips here
today we're going to show them to aaron
and get his thoughts and some breakdowns
from a professional's point of view as
to what makes these stunts special maybe
what makes them bad how they could be
better all right let's take a look
this is one of my favorite things i was
ever a part of
i was deathstroke for a good majority of
this fight
batman is played by phil silvera motion
capture is a lot of fun
there's a lot of freedom for movement
because there's no predetermined agenda
about where camera is going to go or
anything it's just
two people in a volume and you're
capturing movement and if you're a good
movement performer there's a lot of fun
and you see a lot of intricacies about
your own movement what you like
what you don't like and this this was so
much fun because phil's whole thing is
amen
positive contact positive contact bro
i'm like all right bro here we go
this first flip right here was another
gentleman because i i got hurt he does a
really amazing rudy up that was shane
daniels i know shane do you guys know
yeah
wicked that's amazing i think even if i
was doing this i couldn't have done it
any better shane killed it
this whole setup of this gag this is
where i got her when the staff
telescopes and you know he does lachey
up
we were working on that and we were
working on the shane and getting a nice
kip off the thing
phil wanted me to do a gainer and i
worked on the game and i did it a couple
times
and on one of the gainers i over rotated
and i caught my heel
in the porta pit and it just wrenched my
ankle
and it was really interesting because
tim and phil were like hill up
and we want you to finish the scene so
it was really nice of them that they let
me heal and i was able to kind of come
back and finish this and
it meant a lot to me because i love this
whole scene see it's really crazy to me
that like for a scene it's all
animation where theoretically you can
put anybody in a middle cap suit they
would pause production
and let you heal to come back to finish
your role as that character yeah it was
great it was really nice
the fact that they cut to my footwork
you know shuffling steps
i'm a big big advocate of proper
footwork the boxer usually if he's
right-handed dominant he fights with his
left foot forward
those falls that you guys are taking
right there yeah are you doing actual
falls in a mill cap suit or are you
leaving
an animator no we we're actually doing
those oh wow yeah
a lot of the the work we did is
practical some of it's adjusted you know
they do a little adjustments here and
there but for the
most part that's all me and phil
i'm 39 years old now so i'm almost 40. i
should be out of this business i wrote
it down as a bullet point i was like be
done with stunts by 35 30 36 i'm 39. we
are working on falcon and the winter
soldier right now and it's only because
i'm on a show where i want to see this
character through this will be my last
year hopefully
awesome oh yeah you got a girlfriend
no well you do now
meet a nice guy no of it norbit norfolk
in orbit this was my
second job in the business really mm-hmm
i doubled eddie murphy as norbit and
as respusha how was your date
date i was just i just was over at a um
uh western name's wedding rehearsal oh
really
oh man that's a hard one
if you look closely my shoes did fall
off
i'm in my socks oh really yeah
bye-bye shoes that's gnarly so this
scene yeah it was hard but it wasn't
they buried a huge pad in the actual
grass
everything was break away i had no
problems and i just remembered the last
thing i was like this is only my second
job i really don't want to hurt myself
right now and i was
like whatever you do when you go through
the window do this and so when you see
when
i go through the window i'm piked as
much as i can to get to that window
dang dude and they landed you perfectly
on the perfect lap
because they wanted that camera right in
there we dialed that that in for for a
whole day how do you dial it in like do
you just
do it a bunch or do they put like a bag
on there that they do they'll always
test
with a sandbag that equal to your weight
and they'll
dial it in and they'll send that sandbag
out and get readings
as far as where their angle was how much
pressure and how much you know some sort
of stroke they would need to get
the sandbag out and then they put me on
it and then finally you get your
finished product
all right time for a little change of
pace here let's take it back to 1959
no martial arts in this one no martial
arts here just some horses and some
cherries oh
man look at this crazy movie
[Music]
oh dude this is
so sketchy i've seen this scene it's
still like oh
jesus no what i think it's a dummy i
think it's a dummy yes it is
because you can actually see there's no
reaction look at how he falls
yeah a real per person would not fall
like that a real person would go ahead
and cradle themselves as they fell this
guy was very stiff
dude dude dude
oh my god my man you can see him like
crouching down and i'm betting he's
gonna like he's like i gotta jump a
little bit but if you jump too much
you're gonna go flying he absorbs
smart you good good on you sir you
weren't
anticipating that you were not
anticipating that
this is easy acting here you just do it
[Music]
horses but then they cut the nectar on
those horses this is look because they
actually pan up and show you what the
heck
oh my god oh my god
is that a dummy that's right you see how
his arms are stiff
i mean it's also a testament to like the
lost art of using a dummy well
the fact that we're going that doesn't
happen anymore in movies
we can go ahead and see gm and it's like
oh no you could practically use a dummy
i mean they did it here it's great
oh my god that's insane right there is
that is that a dummy no that's no that's
not that i think that's a real person
yeah it looks like a real pr wait but
what about his legs though
what about his legs a lot of times in
this business and i've done done it
before you can wear
sort of a nude layer on captain america
winter soldier i had to bail
off of a car door into the street and i
was wearing a t-shirt
and they basically put a nude layer on
me so that i could wear pads and wear
everything under so i wonder if at some
point he was wearing either moleskin
or had on a nude layer so that he
protected himself also they just tossed
the chariot at four horses there
we're all focused on the dude in the
background there's four horses running
over a chariot
holy crap how does that that thing must
be built on like foam or something
yeah it's got to be really really light
so that it doesn't mess mess with the
horses it doesn't hurt our gentlemen on
the ground
dude yeah because they literally just go
through it no animals were harmed in the
making of this
the dye gets destroyed right my god just
shredded
he's dead and then the real dude looks
like hanging on there i've seen that
stunt before though the guys hanging on
between the horses sketchy as heck
maverick the new one i think micka
rogers did that stunt that's a great
stunt there's a rumor that someone died
while filming this scene
and it kept the shot in the cut against
the witches of the stuntman's widow i've
heard this
so before all you guys freak out and
think we just showed you people dying
that's not true
no one died while filming a scene
apparently no one actually even got
seriously hurt the closest
was that one part where the guy went
over like the front of the chair
he bonked his chin on like the hitch
that was apparently it the rest of it's
all
actually professional controlled stunts
where people didn't get hurt
but it sure doesn't look like it
if you guys are enjoying these videos we
come out with them every saturday
subscribe
so you don't miss it
[Music]
[Applause]
dang it so i had to pull a jackie chan
clip for today's episode
this is from dragons forever with uh
seymour hung in bio and jackie chan
my man this is beautiful
the way this is shot and the way it's
paced yeah you don't see
stuff like this anymore rarely
everything here feels so special
that freaking acrobatics right here yeah
look at this matrix
oh that's where tony john got it from
umbl is the original og of all acrobatic
awesomeness
dude still to this day come on man
you see how thick those those shards are
oh my god he hasn't touched them
i know i didn't even brush them
look at that and you know that he
dropped onto that and probably serrated
himself look at that
oh i'm sure he was all screwed up it's
gotta be candy glass right well yeah
yeah
i would hope so but candy glass can
still cut you can still mess you up
that was a nice setup so it was like
okay i'm just gonna leave you up here
and i'm gonna dump you off and you do
exactly what you need to do
that thing flexes it does definitely not
steel so that's wood
so the team built that that still sucks
oh my god that's painful i don't know if
there's high dense foam
i know that jackie chan later on you
know in years has been a great
advocate about safety but i think this
man just took it look he
hits this really even look at that he
actually used his arm a little bit came
off and he was like okay see it okay
great
what kind of injuries are you looking at
for getting a shot like this lower back
ribs shoulders concussions
dude watch this guy die
do it send it send it
the ledge
is that padded i don't know it's a good
question it looks like it might be but
it i could also just see it not being
added he's wearing a decent enough suit
where he could go ahead and pad his back
he would have to that looks like it
might be like a padded concrete thing on
top of this yeah just a little bit
yeah you're right dude i feel like his
shoulders just popped out of their
sockets
right there so good and then he dies
[Music]
oh this guy there he is
takes his kick so hard it was chin
chin went into his face there's a rope
pull right there too
yeah yeah a little bit how were they
hiding wires in these movies before vfx
well they were
thinner so they they would use piano
wire a lot of time
and there's a reason why they don't
anymore because sometimes things would
snap but for a lot of this you know if
you're just doing hand pulls and stuff
it was great
the biggest thing that sets this aside
from everything else is you have these
performers who can actually do it and
they've trained their entire lives to be
able to do this stuff
yeah and so you can go wide the shot
doesn't have to be crazy
they are the crazy ones yes exactly and
i guess that's why i'm kind of almost
done
with what i'm doing because i feel like
i've done a lot of what i've wanted to
do throughout the years and i want to
get into more and more of this i want to
still
perform but bringing this this back is
very very important
i couldn't agree more you know seriously
i just want to create fights like this
you can i that's the that's one of the
life goals one of the life goals is to
like
totally bring it back like this yeah man
absolutely yeah clint if only we knew
some stunt men who could like
join us no yeah right
i don't know i challenge you guys
to send me a jackie chan clip i don't
know about leave it in the comments
below
we'll take a look at it live right here
on the show and break it down i might
actually have one
okay have you seen thunderbolt is that
the racing one yes
i have not seen it but i know of it he
knows everybody hasn't seen it i think
that counts so nobody can comment
thunderbolt anymore
aaron just took it
sorry this episode of vfx artist react
is brought to you by
raycon let's talk about these everyday
e25s first off
they look sick they're slick these ones
are blue but you can get them in a bunch
of different colors
the everyday e25s have seamless
bluetooth pairing
more bass this time and they come in a
very compact design
look do you like podcasts me too do you
like music yep
it's got you on at least two episodes of
joe rogan podcast
because the battery life on these bad
boys lasts for six hours they come in a
sick
little carrying case that charges the
headphones
the freaking earbuds charge in the case
all right what else could you ask for
are your earbuds dead put them in the
charging case carry it with you
you take them wherever you want the e25
earbuds start at about
half the price of other premium earbud
brands and they sound just as amazing as
the other top audio brands out there
so go to buy recon dot com slash cord or
crew to get 15 percent
off your very own pair let them know who
we sent you
guys thank you so much for watching if
you want to catch more of aaron's work
you can follow him on youtube at erin
tony instagram and twitter
thank you so much for joining us it was
a pleasure it was so good to meet you
and like i'm glad that we were able to
vibe
on all of those stunts together so if
you guys want more of this we do it
every single week so please subscribe
see you guys later